ce qu on est pour ou contre afida turner
au théâtre pour ou contre qui et contre
qui est content jean-mi pourquoi annonce
que je sais c'est pas pour moi c'est
pour molière le pauvre vieux la même
année on le refuse d'entrer au panthéon
et au lui affiche afida turner
[Rires]
alors elle un public est là public elle
a des fans ça ça contestable à les fans
qui aimeraient qu'elle va quelque part
elle attire des gens voilà est-ce que
c'est une actrice pour autant voilà elle
voulait même se présenter à la
présidence et cette année elle a dit oui
j'ai failli présenté il manque seulement
l'argent l'argent et signatures il faut
aussi le programme lesecteur en selle
alors absolument vrai encore une mère
c'est un personnage j'ai encore une
petite vidéo elle que je peux vous
montrer qu'elle chante elle devait
chanter énergie sais pas si on a cette
vidéo
celle-là
survoltage regarder sur cet orgue direct
à l'époque de la matinale c'est quelque
chose ça gic
non
[Musique]
oh
madrid
ça fait pas
[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
face il faut dire faut dire oui tu vas
au théâtre oui non
oui soit et je me suis dit j'ai fait
bien et robin d'un vaisseau en sorte
qu'ils soient qui tu es tu veux y aller
un peu vite us quoi c'est quoi ben quoi
c'est
l'équité c'est même mais non couture
même les fringues son talent mais tous
écoutent chez aubanel sont sales de
téléphone date de jouissance de nice
s'est même écoulé au moins c'est que
c'est une phobie que tu regardes pendant
une demi-heure il ya des gens qui rient
au dix huitième degré dans la salle
située entre les gens vont là bas pour
sur 2 ha gun
pense pas
un troisième nom j'ai un troisième nom
avec florian oui ça fait 20 ans qu'elle
nous fait rire et elle continue sauf que
je peins nouvelle nous fait pas rire
pour les raisons qu'elle pense être les
bonnes c'est à dire que je ne sois pas
que je suis pas convaincu que sa pièce
est drôle par contre les gens se moquent
d'elle depuis 20 ans et des contenus et
patrice pardon c'est une usurpatrice
comme on dit mais je pense qu'elle ne
sait même pas et qu'elle nous accorde
mais c'est elle et elle et elle est
perdue en fait non elle est alors il ya
des gens aussi qui pensent que c'est
bien qu'elles veulent terminer elle et
moi je le connais très bien et les
villes où sophie dion
j'adore
m
c j'adore je fous là
[Musique]
alors
le mec ça fait maintenant on n'a pas vu
il est là ce soir effet les cours
florent s'est plaint on fait les
prolongations au lieu d'encourager
quelqu'un qui se sort de la merde oh
lala média traditionnel
venant toi c'est un c'est un compliment
nab et puis ça origines ex-candidat bébé
on est là où
[Applaudissements]
je me permets de dire question
[Musique]
viens avec moi celle à ta place wada
sommeil voilà voilà voilà notre site web
au dossier quand on est une star comme
toi il forcément des critiques positives
écoute un avis est comme un trou du cul
tout moment
[Applaudissements]
voilà bas les pattes et très gentil non
plus
je ne connais pas on s'en fout d'accord
michel kichka que tu tues tu marches
stupid in victor hugo tu vois qu'il
scelle en relief parce que jamais
personne à venir le voir pendant quinze
jours requiem pour une conne si l'huile
et là il va vers il va vendre 80 80
places dont j'ai passé moins quatre
soldats très bien compris dieu jaloux
par les péchés déjà là tu sais quoi du
coup on va avoir un dernier nom parce
qu'on verra c'est là le courage deborah
pourquoi tu es contre j'ai jamais dit
quel est ton nom dans la main
[Applaudissements]
j'ai discuté avec
mes amis
[Applaudissements]
en fait oui à 3 oui on a trop enfin se
connaît très bien s'hydrater laisser
écouter regarder non mais oui mais oui
on a trop il ya trop de saint trop d'eau
d'huile sur le corps et cheveux trop de
max luycx et ses personnages et surtout
ce que je voudrais dire on a fait un
sujet ensemble comme afida depuis très
longtemps quelle chanson afida turner
alors peut-être que certains ne le
savent pas afida turner a assisté quand
elle était enfant à son père qui a tué
sa mère sous ses yeux elle vient d'une
cité où et comment pardonner ainsi si la
pauvre estime de 2 du nord de la france
elle voulait absolument arriver à faire
quelque chose à être quelque chose mais
les bagages et aujourd'hui elles savent
réellement afida turner elle vit à los
angeles elle a réalisé son rêve alors
peut-être
bien sûr moi je vais pas avoir changé je
vais pas voir ce genre de bien voilà je
méprise pas mais peut-être que le tout
paris qui chante et qui pétillent se
fout d'elle en attendant la le droit de
le faire bravo bravo tu es ce que tu es
mérisant plutôt que les attaquer mais
c'est pas bien de traiter tour à ccc
plein on fait les prolongations les gens
s'éclatent parce que justement
m'attendais pas la même si j'ai fait les
cours florent on t'attendait où c'est le
courant attendu le pape parce que
forcément comme je suis métisse et que
j'ai fait une émission trop populaire on
a beaucoup de gens qui dénigrent mais en
fait ces gens là ils ont fait quoi ils
ont fait rien en fait leur qualité cette
critique et les gens qui ont envie de se
faire une situation où se lever au matin
et ce bal des gens un peu comme ce petit
gros là non
c'est une grosse course
[Applaudissements]
j'allais même du salat et honnêtement je
vais dire exactement ce que je t'aurais
dit ce n'est pas là moi j'ai un malaise
quand je te vois globalement tu sais
c'est le même effet que quand je voi
ouanna sur les plateaux télé pardon je
te compare pas loana c'est qu'à un
moment donné à traiter un petit
bourgeois tu as un petit bourgeois en
quoi
est-ce que tu les protéger non mais
écoutez
donc en fait il aurait parlé pourrait il
aurait voulu que tu as fais toi je ne
parle pas aux ânes ça les instruit toi
t'es pas chez toi tu cherches attentes
dé bay attend bbbb écoute et sa famille
sont vraies mais non là c'est méchant
écoutez vous écouter vous mais je
n'écoute majesté n'ont pas trouvé meriem
j'en veux pas y penser mais disputée
avec toi ça le problème c'est non non
vous n'allez pas brillant mais coûte pas
plus d'argent qui sont autour de nez au
tour de
senna regard des gens regardent
raconte cinéma autour on s'en fout ta
tête bon ben on arrête d'en parler à nos
pages antilles c'est déjà la vie d'un
juger les gens à ouidah
les gens que sait-on sortir maîtrise
rapide aux api d'attenté sont très
basses et moi et moi et moi à merde s'il
te plaît on peut écouter on peut
s'écouter écoute qu'il a à dire et après
tu réponds je vais mais moi ils
m'intéressent ça dérange pas une
reddition mais c'est pas besnehard et je
m'en fous
il écoute le n'est pas dans le match
non s'il te plaît de terminer nous dira
si l'on tape le raid a dirigé 2000 a
franchement dans les yeux jeudi
globalement ce que beaucoup 90 bruges en
belgique pensent de toi et 2e en
fait quoi toi dans ta l'iphone il a fait
faire jouer la finale à une mère
chérie fida tu te grandirais en attend
moins vulgaire en étant plus
respectueuse
[Applaudissements]
mais mon coeur mon coeur pour rappel on
rappelle parce qu'il rappelle que la
pièce a été un succès pendant quatre
semaines et on viendra il mardi mercredi
la semaine prochaine au théâtre c'est
bizarre semaine tu sais quoi et oui et
tu sais quoi et guillaume et moi et
guillaume et moi on verra te voir le
beaucoup plaisir énormément estime aussi
aussi mais là maintenant il faut que tu
te calmes à tout petit peu parce que là
je sens qu'il ya un petit peu de
personnes tous peur je me fais masser
par des gens qui tout à fait fidèle à
mon fils et la fille ne l'apprend
termine que les gens quand on se connaît
suffisamment enfin on
écoute ça peut te servir cela te dit non
mais ça n'est pas une mauvaise personne
constructive comme comme il n'est
affilié à ce qui peut pas dire de
quelqu'un il m'intéresse pas parce qu'il
va pas me faire faire un film n'y a pas
que les gens avec qui vont de ma vie je
me dis que ça m'a fait pas quant à jean
paul gaultier qui vient voir et se met
se permet de critiquer mais aux dévôts
fois mais c'est son frère éric gauthier
merci beaucoup
rapaille est ronde assurant des tisanes
et encore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]